vr is definitely like that the first
time you're like holy [ __ ] and then you
realize that you're like sweating a lot
and then you're you've burned like 10
000 calories so you're having so much
fun
have you played this game called gorilla
tag
it's
on the topic of vr uh so connor connor
had his housewarming party the other day
and uh chris was there and uh seeing
chris try vr for the first time what's
the [ __ ] sight to begin we gave chris
a few drinks and i was like i was like
drinks i was like chris uh you should
try playing super hot
[Laughter]
and chris said i missed out dude he was
like rolling on the floor doing like
jumps and [ __ ] like like james bond in
my bedroom smacking the walls like
nearly broke all my jojo's first thing i
see i walk in and chris is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] punching someone he punches like
joe a jojo poster right there broke it
like he's full on punching and vr like
i'm like chris it's okay
my god nearly destroyed my apartment
he was like what is this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
he put it on he loved it that's classic
crazy well that's vr right it's like
i've tried to talk so many people into
vr and they're just like nah i don't get
it it's probably not for me it's
definitely one of those things that you
just have to try
and it's like once you try it then you
fully understand like you could give a
[ __ ] dissertation on why vr is
awesome and you probably couldn't get i
mean like the thing about vr is that i i
can only play vr for a certain amount of
time before i just
just feels less casual you know i don't
know i swear a lot you're gonna play you
gotta play gorilla tag that's where the
real what's gorilla type how do you play
it's exactly what it sounds like you're
gorillas and you tag each other oh boy i
did it on stream right um i thought it
would just be like chasing people yeah
turns out it's just like 10 year olds
just like
playing as a guerrillas what do you mean
it's like it's all 10 year olds i joined
a lobby and 10 year olds are like
swearing and saying horrible things and
i was like so it's just xbox live
if you want to export go and play
gorilla tag right because what happens
is the way you connor gets to relive his
childhood that's why he loves you so
much
i did not like this i realized the power
you have as a kid is is unobtainable as
an adult those kids could say and do
anything and i i can't i can't say that
[ __ ] back to them it's just so unfair
the kid the kids can say whatever they
want and it's like it's unfair i want to
be able to call that kid a little [ __ ]
why not why can't you call that i'm on
stream i can't say it off stream i'll
say
what were they saying to you they were
saying words that you cannot say on
stream okay okay you know what you
streaming and i was streaming there's a
clip of me i go in i go in a world i
join it and one of the kids is saying
the word that you cannot say yeah and i
was like all right then gonna go away
and then just left the world because he
was
this 10 year old kid was screaming it
but it's really fun right so you do is
you have the controllers yeah and you
they act like it sounds like a bunch of
apes in there
so you have two two of the vr
controllers right yeah and those are
your your legs and your arms so when you
want to move you have to like jump with
the legs
off them right and people are insane in
it these kids are insane they're like
flying across the map and i can barely
move i've really felt like a boomer
you should play gorilla tag oh how how
long do you play vr for though how long
did you stream for three hours four
hours
did you all get sweaty because that's
extremely slightly okay that's that's
that's what puts me on vr it's like i
stream for like i play for an hour i get
really sweaty and then you you take you
you don't take the vr self you [ __ ]
peel it off at that point right but just
just doesn't feel good at least the
index has the um removable face thing
yeah so you can like clean it
so i didn't feel too disgusted by it
right so you're just like cycling
through the foam the foam parts i'm like
cleaning it a lot okay which headset are
you using uh i'm using the uh valve
index okay yeah yeah yeah super good i
hate wires though i hate that why is the
only thing that like take you out of it
i feel like yeah i feel like
once it once it gets like wireless
headsets that are like high quality then
i would get more invested into vr oculus
2 right is like the the wireless one
right yeah i think it's not as the specs
aren't as good as the index though but i
mean it's still it's pretty good from
what i've heard yeah i haven't streamed
on my oculus 2 yet but just i bought it
just because i heard that there's no
wires i'm like yeah it's good
the index is like super easy to use
was that the first time you tried vr or
had you tried vr before your stream ah
yeah actually to be honest i kind of
wasn't interested at all in it but you
know emilia is like the the tech wizard
um in myth and she was just kind of like
hey what if we did a big vr collab for
our anniversary and all of us were like
okay but how and she's like no it's
super easy and she told us everything we
needed to buy that sounds like a
technical nightmare
oh my god
oh my god you might imagine trying to
like schedule that and sort that [ __ ]
out i go through enough technical issues
just like
just streaming on my pc on my own let
alone like doing a cross-continental vr
stream oh my god
motion capture she worked really hard